so I am here to introduce the next
speaker and typically I will try to find
a bunch of embarrassing things to say
about him uh and make fun of him and
whatever because that's what we usually
do with one another because we've been
close friends uh but I won't um I just
want to introduce him as a really swell
guy um although I will say that he has
made me do some really bizarre things
for this conference and for the one in
New York but I will not go into details
uh but seriously uh I I love
participating in this uh I you know I
asked Jared to I've been going to the
art conference in New York for a long
time and having run the meet up here for
a while I'm like Jared let's do this in
DC so I guess you know I kind of nudged
them and nudged him until he gave up one
day and said all right fine Mark leave
me alone we'll do this uh so really uh
it just gives me great pleasure to
introduce uh my good friend and host uh
for this event uh Jared L all
right so today we're going to be talking
about making big maps and by that I mean
maps with a lot of information in them
not just big maps you can put on the
wall I'm jaral lard you may remember me
from previous GS talks such as using R
for GIS and
mapping now this talk I gave was both
about making maps and about big
computations and I love doing the big
computations I'm not miked oh no I'm
sorry hope that worked in the zoom
that's so much better thank you hope
that picked up on the zoom should I
start over yeah all right so I love
doing big computations I love taking a
six-hour geospatial query making it run
in three seconds that's great um but
today we're gonna be talking about
making maps and that previous talk I did
talk about making making maps including
how to triangulate Solutions in worldle
this is not worldle it's world I can't
pronounce it and basically it is the um
map version of worldle where they show
you an outline of a country and you have
six guesses to figure out what country
it is and one time they gave me some
uninhabited island in the middle of the
South Pacific Ocean and I had to use
triangulation for my previous guesses in
order to find bouvet Island which I had
never heard of and so today's Focus will
be on maps I am a big fan of maps uh
particularly tm's world map I mean
that's a great map this is based on tm's
description of the world and it's not
accurate at all but we're going to be
talking about mapping large data sets
taking a lot of data and displaying it
on a map which is particularly important
for a number of my
clients so we are going to be looking
today at leaflet we're not going to be
looking at static Maps we're just going
to look at leaflet they're web-based
generated in JavaScript so they're
interactive they're zoomable they're
pable and the tentacle term for that is
slippy it's a slippy
map so big is relative what is big I
mean Big 10 years ago is not big today
big for a laptop is not big for a
server so before we even get to Maps
let's talk about files and let's talk
about file
sizes and for this section we're just
going to talk about Point data dots on a
map that's all we're going to look at
right now okay so here's a data set I
loaded it up and I saved as an SF object
and this only has 325,000 rows that's
not really big by any measure for
regular data but let's see how it looks
in different file formats some common
geospatial
formats the easiest is a CSV one record
per row and it's nicely laid out you
have all your information all your other
columns you have a column for latitude
and a column for longitude and yes I'm
focusing just on latitude and longitude
data it's very simple but it's really
only good for Point data yes you could
Jam a polygon in there but we're not
getting into
that perhaps more common in the
geospatial realm is geojson data it's
Json but for
geo it's very verbose every column name
which are now Fields is repeated for
every record so you're getting a lot of
extra information there what Edward tuy
would call chart junk but it's data junk
a lot in there so it's very
verbose similarly we have KML
which looks a lot like XML which is also
verbose a lot of repetition a lot of a
lot of junk in
there and I'm not even going to show you
shape
files they're not real files it's like
five files and you just read in one file
but all the other four come with it it's
crazy so let's look at how big are these
files you can see the CSV is the
smallest at 35
megabytes right goj Json is 107
megabytes and KML is 144 megabytes for
300,000 rows of data these are
incredibly
huge so the CSV is the smallest but it's
only good for Point data geojson is
better for other data but it's much
bigger and this is not large data by
regular
standards but there's a new there's a
new file format there's a new one that's
going to come to our rescue and be
better than all of these hopefully Geo
par it's par but for
geo if you don't know par it is a
columnar data format that saves the dis
it's compressed it's fast and it's
related to Arrow like Geo Arrow also Now
Arrow is in memory par is on disk and
when we look at this the size of this
file is 16
megabytes it's half the size of CSV a
tenth the size of KML and it's much
faster to read and write also so that's
really
nice but how do we create these files we
need to somehow make these files unless
they're just magically handed to you
from the Census website which doesn't
come in park maybe it does now well it's
easy with SF you could use WR SF to
write most of them you can write to CSV
you can write to geojson you can write
to KML you can write to shape files
which I'm not going to do and if you
want to use Park you could use the Geo
Arrow package which is not on cran yet
and you could use write Park from that
package and will write to a special Geo
Park file if you're stuck in the command
line you could use ogr to ogr or G doll
to convert between different
formats back to maps though today we're
supposed to be talking about putting
this big data in these files into
Maps so we're going to start with points
on a map I just want to draw dots on the
map that's all I want to do right now so
we're going to use leaflet and we are
going to call leaflet which is like GG
plot it initiates the map then we're
going to say add tiles to put these
background tiles on there then add
circles to actually put each lat long
combination and yes you do need to think
is it lat long or is it long lat and
whichever way you do it is
wrong GIS cannot agree which way it goes
now you'll see here I sampled the data
for just about 4,000 rows because a
regular leaflet once you get past about
4,000 points on the map you're pretty
much hitting its limits give or take
depending on your machine it doesn't
matter the machine that generates it
it's the machine that loads it because
all those 4,000 points have to be
written into an HTML file as SVG which
is essentially like
XML and then each point has to be
rendered on the screen so we pretty much
maxed out and 4,000 points isn't big so
we're going to leave points behind for a
minute we'll come back to points later
and see ways to deal with it because
first I want to talk about polygons
these are shapes with area
so easy polygons to think about is the
outline of country borders you think
that's easy getting all of the different
countries as a data set and knowing
where the borders are it's not easy to
get clean data it's really hard and in
fact this data set from our Natural
Earth has 177
rows but the UN says there's 190 plus
countries what happened to them here I
don't know that's not the point of
today's talk we just want to plot them
so I'm going to just plot the first 50
Maps first 50
countries that's because even though
there's only 50 polygons when you're
plotting it you don't have 50 polygons
you have every single verticy in that
polygon verticy vertex you have every
single vertex in that polygon so for
just 50 countries for this Soo
resolution map that's over 4,700
vertices so that's 4,700 dots it needs
to draw connect the lines and fill in
the area that's hard if we wanted to do
all 177 countries represented that would
be over 10,000 points it needs to draw
and we already know that leaflet is not
going to handle that okay now of course
with coastlines you have the coastline
Paradox which I don't think's really a
paradox it's not paradoxical the more
you zoom in the more curvy it can get
all right so Bas leaflet is not going to
cut it fortunately there are leaflet
extensions like Leaf GL
Leaf GL uses webg to draw the maps webg
is a high-speed JavaScript plotting
Library it can plot data it can plot
Network graphs it can make bar charts it
can make Scatter Plots whatever there's
a number of packages for working with
webg but specifically we will use Leaf
GL to make our
maps and we are going to return to the
points here instead of saying add
circles we are going to say add GL
points and now on here I'm plotting
250,000 dots on the map in an
interactive map this slideshow if you
come here you can zoom in you can click
on points you can pan around with
250,000 points being
displayed now I did 250,000 points
because I'm cramming a bunch of maps
into the self-contained slideshow if I
was just making one map I could
definitely get to over 400,000 points
which is a big improvement over base
leaflet it renders really quickly but
now the thing is you still have to
encode 400,000 points into the HTML file
still being written in and that can
really get big I was working on a
project for a client I made 10 different
Maps using Leaf GL each one showing a
few hundred thousand points the HTML
file was 1.5
gigabytes it got a little out of
hand so you got to think about what
you're doing and we'll come back to
points in a little bit we'll see more
ways to deal with points by want to go
revisit polygons using Leaf GL once
again instead of doing add polygons I'm
doing add GL
polygons now little caveat where you
have ADD polygons from leaflet it can
handle multi- polygons which are
multiple polygons on a single record
Leaf GL can only handle regular polygons
so you need to cast your multi- polygon
into a regular polygon which just bakes
breaks it up into multiple rows and then
call Leaf GL and you can see now I'm
plotting all 177 rows of country data
with no problem
okay is New Zealand on the map yes it is
good I always want to make sure for
that now another nice feature about
using GL polygons is that it's so much
easier to color code with regular
leaflet I need to get a color ramp and
then uh figure out which country is map
to which colors with Leaf GL I just say
fill color equals some column name and I
put the column name in quotes or F till
day and it's done so that's nice simple
easy now with Leaf GL it's harder to
make a legend in leaflet but making
Legends in leaflet is hard anyway so how
much harder is
it now I promise you we'd come back to
the points
data I want to instead of showing the
the the points data in raw format I want
to summarize them to do that I'm going
to use hex bins I'm going to break up
the world into little hexagons and count
how many points falls into each hexagon
and color code according to that point
thankfully this is easy using a package
called H3 H3 is an open source piece of
software written by
Uber and what it does it breaks the
world into a bunch of hexagons all
around the world at 15 different levels
of Zoom the more you zoomed in the
smaller the hexagon is when you're
zoomed out the bigger the hexagon is
there are multiple packages in R for
interacting with H3 I'm using H3 jsr
which calls the JavaScript binding for
H3 through the V8
package then what I do is I use point to
cell to convert any gome point any lat
long into a deterministic hexagon on the
earth for a given level of
Zoom then I use regular D plier to count
the number of points which fall on each
of these hexagons then I want to convert
this hexagon back into a plottable
polygon so I say cell to polygon and
then I have polygons again which I could
go using my maps so nice simple calcul a
few lines of code does the counting for
me and I know how many points occurred
inside of each
polygon and then you make a map all I'm
changing now is the data set to use add
GL polygons I give it my hexagons and
then I color code based on the log scale
that's so easy because instead of
putting the column in quotes I do till
day log of the column and it will take
the log scale of my data and make it
nice and easy to plot and we've
essentially made a heat map on a map and
that's pretty cool great way to
visualize now another idea that we
kicked
around was showing different types of
objects at different Zoom
levels maybe we want to have the
summarized hexagons when you're zoomed
out and you want to have points when
you're zoomed in so you make your map
you start with leaflet you add your
tiles you add your polygon
you add your points then you use group
options to say this layer this group The
Polygon Group for Zoom levels 1 through
three and the points group for Zoom
levels 4 through 15 so when you zoomed
out it shows the polygons when you
zoomed in it shows the
points right now I'm not showing you the
map yet I'm just saving it to an object
on the next page we'll look at it at
zoom level three and a zoom level four
the only difference between these two
maps that use the map code I just
created one is zoomed in at level three
one is at level four and between them it
switches to points now I'm showing them
side by side but in reality actually
when you come to this talk later you
could actually zoom in on one and watch
it change that's really great right you
think okay well that only shows data is
not going to blow things up but it does
because even though you're only
rendering one type of geometry at a time
you still have to write all the data to
HTML so now I've written all of my
300,000 points to the HTML and I've
written all 17,000 polygons Each of
which has six vertices so I've still
blown up my map in fact for this talk
I'm showing the map twice so I've done
that all
twice right this presentation is pretty
large remember that 1.5 gigabyte HTML
file you don't want to do that to
yourself so this was like the
state-ofthe-art for a while okay let's
use shiny to stream in data but then I
was directed to something called PM
tiles by Tim Apple Hans I done well I've
asked for a lot of Twitter driven
development I would tweet at Tim he
would make a new feature I would tweeted
him you make new features it's awesome
he's really helped out a
lot I've dreamt of only streaming points
to the map that are in the viewport that
would be visible on the map so whatever
you're zoomed in on just show that data
but how do you get the data to the
viewport in the first place hell how do
you even know which points fall in the
viewport I was thinking like we'll talk
to a database and do like a geospatial
join around the the bounding
box it was bad and how do you even
prevent it from choking when you're
zoomed out when You' be showing
everything luckily that's all
solved so first you need to create a
special TM files a PM tiles file to do
that use Tippy Cano this can switch
between different file formats and what
I'm doing here I'm calling Tippy can-
z15 says allow it to zoom up to level 15
and cluster points at higher Zoom so
that means if I'm zoomed out if I'm
zoomed in let's start there might be 50
points at a certain zoom level when you
zoom out there are 10 points when you
zoom out further there are three points
they're like an amalgamation of the
lower points I'm writing it to
locations. PM tiles and I'm using my
locations full. geojson as the spots
layer and you could have multiple layers
in this one PM tiles
file next you need to serve the file it
needs to be served somewhere you can use
an S3 bucket like AWS or Azure or
digital Ocean or back Blaze or you can
run your own file server like engine
X the thing
is you need to allow cross origin
resource sharing cores and according to
the manual the documentation it's easy
to do I have not found it easy not at
all and what this means is you need to
allow a file being served up by a web
server on one domain to be viewed by
another web server maybe coming from
your laptop maybe coming from like the
serving server and it's not easy to
do so PM tiles is really
cool now normally what I would do is IID
package a web server like enginex in a
Docker container and use that but I
couldn't do that for this talk so I
tried using Amazon but it wasn't easy to
do so I'm using a prean data set I'm
actually using the example from the
documentation showing you breweries in
Germany and you do this by using the
leaf M package Leaf em and in there
there's a function called add PM points
but it's not on cray it's the
development version from GitHub okay and
you do that and then you pass it the URL
for the PM tiles which could be an S3
bucket or a web server and it plots all
the points that you can see now if we
were to zoom in on this map as you zoom
in these black dots break apart into
more dots and as you zoom in it breaks
into more so any given level it streams
in in from the web server just a certain
number of points based on what's visible
if I were to pan to the left and only a
certain part of Germany was visible
there would be fewer dots it's streaming
in data as it's being used
live this is it this is the Holy Grail
for me as long as I can spin up a web
server adjacent to my web server my my
map server it's there it's like having
your own tile server for Vector tiles
it's really
fantastic so now that we've hit our
ultimate goal
what are the key takeaways from
everything we've
done well the type of file matters CSV
is only good for Point data and it's the
smallest but geojson is way more common
but it's huge but geop par is actually I
said CSV is smaller CSV is the smallest
of the common format geop par is even
smaller than CSV and it's faster and
it's easier but it's not plain text it's
a binary file so you want to open it up
in a text editor good luck and going to
talk about shape
FES for the most part you want to use
Leaf GL Beyond a few thousand points
leafl will freak out so you're going to
use Leaf GL to utilize web GL as the
back end and you're going to use
functions like AGL points or AGL
polygons and this allows you to plot
hundreds of thousands of points so this
is pretty much your Panacea this is what
you're good
with and if you want to do
summarization bin your data use H3 it
creates hexagon for these are
deterministic at level three Zoom these
are hexagons all tiled across the Earth
you don't need to make them up as you go
they are done so they are fast to
compute it's like a lookup table my I
have this lat long it does a look up to
H3 it's amazing so thanks Uber for that
but if you have really big data you're
going to use PM tiles only loads of
points that you need serves them
remotely it's pretty fast now it's
relatively new but there already support
in leaf M and you can write your own
custom JavaScript if you really need to
PM tiles for big is the way to go so
thank you very
much